prime minister i i'd like to start this
conversation with the bombing in maripo
yesterday of the children's hospital
putin appears to have committed a war
crime
what will it take for the west to get
directly involved in this is killing
children and pregnant women not enough i
think what happened in mariopol in that
uh maternity hospital really shows that
putin is prepared
just to
reject to abandon all norms of of
civilized behavior and the sort of
cynicism with which uh the russian
uh
sergey lavrov admitted that they'd
attacked that uh maternity hospital
shows the the the depth to which they
will stoop and
what we will do of course we are we
already are involved beth in the sense
that uh we are uh from the beginning the
uk was the first european donor of
defensive military equipment we've
massively ramped that up and
what we're doing now is as you can see
is tightening the device tightening the
uh the pressure on
vladimir putin's regime through economic
sanctions and targeting not just uh
swift not just his banks uh but uh as
many of his uh people who are known to
be associated with him as as we possibly
can
i i think that you know when you look at
something like the the mario party i
mean i was really i don't know i think
many of many of our viewers must have
been absolutely yeah lavrov said
concerns over civilian casualties were
to quote him pathetic shrieks you know
but i'm afraid that is just where they
are and you
and that is what we're dealing with and
i'll i'll make you one other prediction
by the way which is that the stuff that
you're hearing about uh
chemical weapons is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that uh
there are chemical weapons that have
been stored by uh their opponents or by
the americans and so when they
themselves deploy uh chemical weapons as
i as i fear they they may they have us a
a sort of a mask erotica of a fake story
ready to go you've seen it in syria uh
you you saw it in even in the uk when
this is what you expect next then look i
you know it's i just note that that is
what they're they're already doing it is
a cynical uh barbaric uh
government i'm afraid and so on your
point about beth on your point about uh
war crimes
i think it's the right question to ask
and
as it happens uh the the lord chancellor
the deputy prime minister dom raab has a
lot of experience in this he was one of
those uh who was involved in uh putting
slobodan milosevic before the the hague
for trial the the the serb uh leader
uh
for for war crimes and he will be going
off to to the hague to see what uh they
need what what evidence we can help but
in the meantime prime minister the
bombing of an attorney hospital at least
516 civilians have been killed the use
of cluster bombs thermobaric weapons the
threat of chemical weapons troops
opening fire on fleeing families
shelling of civilian humanitarian
corridors airstrikes on residential
blocks is it not on your conscience
every time you speak to president
zielenski and he asks you for that
no-fly zone it must it is
and it's terrible i gotta say it's
absolutely terrible and
uh i've got a massive aberration for
vladimir zelinski and i think any leader
in his position
would be saying exactly the same thing
they'd be saying
why can't you
provide that air cover why can't you as
the west uh simply help to clear our
skies of of russian planes and stop us
being bombarded from the air stop this
this evil going on in europe and and you
know we've had some some
very frank conversations and ones in
which which have been deeply
upsetting
the difficulty is that well the
difficulty is that uh there is a
there is a line
uh beyond which
quite frankly the the uk nato would be
would be deemed to be
in conflict direct conflict so there's
no russia so no circumstances if they if
as you say
they could uh drop chemical weapons is
that not the red light nothing well is
there nothing
that could happen that might make you
change your mind it's agonizing it's
absolutely agonizing and i've had this
conversation
uh
at least a couple of times now with with
vladimir
but i think the difficulty is that it
would require me
to order
raf jets uk pilots
into the air with a mission to shoot
down russian fast jets
and that is something that
all my life
literally all my life all my childhood i
remember something that we
uh we did everything we possibly could
to avert because that would be conflict
between uh two p5 nuclear powers
no circumstances no circumstances that
can that happen is that what i think
we've got to be realistic and we're
going to do everything we can to
support the ukrainian people to support
the
amazing heroic ukrainian resistance
and we're we're doing more and more uh
with uh support from uh from with their
with uh
their defenses uh with anti-tank
weaponry and all that kind of thing i
don't want to go into the the details
but i think i think our viewers know
roughly what we're we're doing it has
been it has been ramped up but there is
that is that is effectively a defensive
country but i just want to stress that
there's no western country i know where
that is that is on the agenda what you
speak to president zlensky a lot every
time you put the phone down to him do
you wonder whether that might be the
last conversation that you'll have here
i think i think vladimir has been one of
the
most extraordinary leaders of of recent
times in the way he's rallied he's only
rallied his people he's rallied the
whole world to the cause of ukraine and
he's made us all wear
uh
yellow and blue
flags and he's got ev he's got everybody
mobilized on his side i think
because he's so clearly and and
and brilliantly delineated
the difference between right and wrong
in this case everybody can see that this
is an unjustified act of aggression he
did an interview in on sky news last
night he said he thinks millions of
people could die do you think millions
of people could die in this conflict i
think that it depends on putin and it's
up to him and to him alone and that
everybody can see that things aren't
progressing in the way that uh he hoped
prime minister and
and his best bet i think is to withdraw
uh to cease the uh the violence and uh
and and to allow
a peaceful negotiation to begin let's go
on to vladimir putin two weeks into this
war it's already unbearable to see the
images coming out of the ukraine your
foreign secretary said it could last a
decade do you agree with that
i think that
again that depends on uh on on putin
but what i certainly think is that the
ukrainians
themselves and the
will to resist in ukraine will never be
extinct i get that but how is it going
to go on for you you heard that from a
volatile experience for the long haul i
think i think that
my own view is that
uh
vladimir putin can
either choose to accept that he's made a
catastrophic mistake now or accept that
he's made a catastrophic mistake a bit
later on and that's the that's the
difference between the two options he
faces how long
that is i'm afraid up to this
you know i wish i
bet i wish i wish that the
that i could tell you how long it will
be i think that you know he has said uh
that he wants to give the military
operations till the end of of this month
you've heard what putin's own narrative
is i myself don't believe i don't think
most people looking at the situation uh
believe
he i don't think that he can he can
conquer ukraine
45 million people but prime minister you
keep saying that putin must fail i do
but do you acknowledge that putin in his
mind must be seen to win
that's the problem you keep saying he's
going to fail but he has to win so how
do we get out of this i i think that he
i think that he needs to understand
that his options are not good i'm not
good but you accept that that he needs
to have some sort of victory what's the
off ramp well when you say when you say
needs uh that that i don't know what you
quite mean by means
what i think is that
the best way out for for russia for the
russian people uh is for
withdrawal of the russian forces and
uh for
total
cessation of hostilities uh for
reparations and i think
we will all have to work together to
rebuild ukraine
be in no doubt but uh that's that's just
that's just the beginning but you accept
that you won't be able to i think you i
think you've put your finger on
something very important which is that
i think that vladimir putin has himself
made it very difficult
to
find an off-ramp and he has i think uh
driven his
uh his tanks so to speak down a a
cul-de-sac from which it will be very
hard to extricate himself but but he
must but in the meantime millions of
people are going to die so how do you
help him get an off ramp i mean what's
the compromise what's the compromise
should
ukraine say okay we'll withdraw
application for nato or i mean what it
all i guess i want to say is all i see
is escalation and i understand the
sanctions and but there's it's
escalating there's no de-escalation and
in the meantime millions of people could
die i think what needs to happen first
of all is that putin needs to understand
that he's made a catastrophic
miscalculation and he needs to to
withdraw he needs to stop killing
innocent people in in ukraine i i then
think that uh there is
certainly a space for a a conversation
about the future but
it's got to be in those in that context
and it's got to be something that uh the
people of of ukraine and uh the
ukrainian government actively want beth
and i think this is the crucial thing i
don't think that you can have a
conversation about ukraine without
ukraine they've got to be they've got to
be at the table but it does seem to me
and they've got to be they've got to be
they've got to be willing to but you
can't see a way
you can't see a way out at the moment i
can't see a way out that doesn't begin
with the realization uh by
the uh yeah the kremlin that they've
made a catastrophic mistake and that
it's time to
begin uh to withdraw and we'll draw
immediately so
let me just move on to sort of domestic
response and your leadership over that
um
in terms of sanctions today you finally
sanctioned roman abramovich and six
other oligarchs something people have
been calling for for a couple of weeks
now uh it's been welcome but do you
acknowledge you could have moved more
quickly on this and you wish you had i
think the uk has been absolutely out in
front in uh the whole sanctions process
and don't just listen to to me listen to
what the uh the ukrainians have said
look at what the the kremlin themselves
have have said about the uk's role in
this we
drove the sanctions
don't forget that we've already done uh
two or three hundred individuals and in
the uk we have uh pretty tight
protections of
of property rights uh from tuesday uh
we'll be able to go uh much further and
faster because we're changing the law
under the economic crime bill what we've
been able to do with the individuals
who've been sanctioned
today is to look at their
relationship uh with the russian
regime
the due process has been gone through
all the evidence has been assembled
which is the right thing to do and
they've been sanctioned and
in a very tough way but that's the
that's the way we've had to do it when
you campaign to take back control was it
so that when we have issues like ukraine
crisis that you can be more restrictive
than the european union when it comes to
visas no because if you look at what
we're we're doing we're historically and
and uh by nature
a very very generous and uh open
welcoming people but we've only wanted
to only issued a thousand people
well that was the number yesterday and
i'm it's rising the whole time and it
will rise you personally intervened
very sharply so you had to pass and
intervene on uh on monday
uh you'll get from the
uh from uh from the leveling up
secretary uh you'll get uh the program
that will allow people to come in so
people people want to welcome it into
their own homes they can do so you ask
i know you've said about checks in the
need for biometric testing but half of
the refugee half of the two million
refugees
estimated to believe a children you
don't need to biometrically test a child
i mean it seems a bit heartless someone
actually said to me yesterday a cabbie
he said it's really heartless why don't
they just wave the visa checks i i'll
tell you why so so for younger people
were not being uh as uh we're not making
those requirements but what we are doing
is in ensuring that uh
and i think this is the best thing also
for for refugees because they want a
scheme that is safe uh that is welcoming
and that works and
if you've been to uh war zones and as
i'm sure you have as as i have you'll
know all sorts of things that are going
on there and
and you and you'll you'll find that um
there are people coming out of them who
perhaps uh for one reason or another
don't have the the papers that uh they
need and may even have false papers they
may have a good reason for that but it
is sensible given the uh
the attitudes of the putin regime
towards the uk uh it is sensible to have
uh to have checks so by the end of the
year and they are they are like
thousands
touch checks but i think that most
people can see the case prime minister
i've got so many more questions
on the numbers it could go up yeah uh
you know just on the family reunion
thing uh you could have a very large
number indeed because there are so many
potential uh
uh
beneficiaries of that scheme that's
great but i mean as i said in the
comments yesterday i'm proud as is the
as is dom rob as the deputy prime
minister as is uh the home secretary
we're all the direct descendants of of
refugees and
our government
has done a lot if you look at the people
we took from afghanistan uh the numbers
we've taken
from hong kong from hong kong
so i know i know what i view our viewers
will want to know because what the
british people want to know is are we
going to be generous and my answer is
overwhelming okay
because at the moment we haven't done
very well
i think the public are a bit annoyed i
also think people want us uh to have
chat yeah but i think people are annoyed
that we haven't done more i think people
i think people you must accept
and this is about you leveling with the
british people about the cost at home of
this yes okay
energy bills could go up to 3000 by 3
000 pounds uh
oil prices i mean do you even know what
the cost of a litre of petrol now is i
it's it's it's high it's it's 160 pounds
it is
how bad is it going to be can you just
level with people let me just explain
they're going to have to take so we will
do everything so we've frozen the fuel
duty for instance for
uh for 12 years and and we will continue
to to do that um we will do everything
we can to help households help people
with the cost of fuel particularly uh
elderly vulnerable people and you you
you know all the packages of of support
we're putting in even more that the
chancellor announced the the other day
that's not going to be enough on its own
so
uh the best thing for dealing with the
cost of living i mean big picture yeah
is to have
a strong economy good high-wage high
school jobs such as such as the ones
that we're creating throughout with our
shipbuilding strategy which you which
you haven't mentioned uh even though
we're in this uh this shipyard
you could have done but i'm going to
mention it before unit
i'm going to just slide it in there uh
this is the the this is the this is that
we are launching our
national
and this is
absolutely vital
uh
not just have a high wage high school
economy uh with with with record
employment and almost record low youth
unemployment which is a great thing uh
what we're gonna do is look at our
energy supply and what putin is doing
is proving how wrong we were in 2014 uh
not to move away
as europeans and the uk did more than
other european countries uh but we could
do still more to move away from
dependence on russian oil and gas and so
so what i'm saying to you beth is that
now is the time and it may be a bumpy uh
period but we will get through it as
fast and as well as we possibly can now
is the time to unleash an extraordinary
program of energy
independence through through uh massive
investment in renewables in more nuclear
a lot more nuclear and also in sensible
use of our own
hydrocarbons with our own oil and gas
and without busting our car we're going
to have to take the pain we're trying to
defeat putin aren't we and so and
so
yes i think that is right i think that
the wet i'm absolutely right beth i
think that the west is going to have to
learn the lesson
of indulging and appeasing putin and
failing
to wean ourselves off russian oil and
gas and we are now going to do the
dramatic steps that we need to take to
have independent energy supply so that
we're no longer capable of being
blackmailed by putin and that i think is
the right thing to do prime minister
thank you very much thank you